tristan cabello on entendait une de ses
dames nous dire les pauvres voilà elles
seront certainement pauvre il ne faut
pas éluder cette énorme crise également
aux états unis dans un contexte de crise
due qu'au guide très aigu ça va être
compliqué la tâche qui attend le nouveau
président ça va être très compliqué en
effet un mon collègue le rappeler juste
avant l'élection de joe guidance et
c'est le retour du libéralisme du
néolibéralisme à la tête de l'état et
donc dubaï dont a toujours décrit comme
quelqu'un qui était centriste modéré
bon quand on veut être un peu cynique
avec lui on se rend compte aussi que
c'est quelqu'un qui est quand même
souvent tombés en accord avec les
républicains avec le côté droit du parti
démocrate
il ya quand même de quoi se réjouir ou
un peu avoir de l'espoir
lorsqu'on regarde quand même son co sont
à discours du 14 janvier où il décrit
son plan de relance
il ya là des accents un peu jones aux
liens de la great society donc une
augmentation des minimums sociaux une
augmentation du du chômage d'échec de
stimulus qui vont être envoyées aux
américains de ça va dans la bonne
direction mais encore une fois il faut
quand même rappeler que 60% des
américains n'ont pas
400 dollars sur leurs sur leur compte
épargne c'est un pays qui est vraiment
en crise le chômage est très haut
12 millions de gens qui vont perdre leur
leur logement au mois de janvier février
donc il ya vraiment une crise sanitaire
qui se superposent la crise économique
sociale et institutionnelle que joe
biden va devoir va devoir régler